olympus has fallen i'll let mrs fallen
that's code for the white house is being
blown to [ __ ] this movie is an
action-packed high-concept tale about
the white house being overtaken by a
korean with mommy issues with all it has
going for it it's surprisingly just an
okay movie yes gerard butler is a badass
he's the best thing in this movie he
should have had more scenes plus he can
finally do an american accent he doesn't
sound like this anymore this is the ugly
truth and his mouth is not on the right
side of his face anymore but truth be
told you don't find yourself strongly
rooting for this guy there's also a
solid supporting cast but there's really
nothing special there this is an action
film so how is the action at first it's
great the first half sets up solid
characters great suspense a sense of
realism behind the violence but then
once it turns into a generic action
movie that's where the film's impact
withers away olympus has fallen online
business falling it stops becoming
suspenseful the action becomes just okay
there's a bad guy who's
bad but he's really not that interesting
there's some really awful cinematography
it looks like this now imagine trying to
watch an action scene with that kind of
lighting the film's biggest problem is
its tone it seemed like it didn't know
if i wanted to be a fun action flick or
a serious patriotic action-american
drama so its patriotic moments seem
unintentionally cheesy it's like they
want you to be cheering for america yay
but by the end of this movie not one
person clapped there are moments
throughout where you should be clapping
but you don't but honestly if you're an
action junkie the film is action-packed
gerard butler is the [ __ ] so although i
personally didn't care too much for die
hard in the white house i can see how
action junkies would appreciate it let
me get straight to the point here all in
all i gotta say olympus has fallen got
it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my video if you want please go ahead and
tell me your points below in the comment
boxes and if you want to see a more
in-depth review of olympus has fallen
that i do with my buddy jerry called
reasons to see where we give you a
breakdown of reasons to see and reasons
not to see olympus has fallen go ahead
and click on the link right here just
click on the little picture it's a good
picture and last but not least if you
want to get updated every time a new
review is out go ahead and subscribe to
my channel